[Musique]
bonjour on va parler d'intelligence
artificielle on va parler aussi du
nouveau monde celui du metavers avec mon
invité antoine board bonjour
vous êtes vous êtes le directeur du
laboratoire de recherche en intelligence
artificielle de meta
m'est assez on va expliquer baisser
c'est le nouveau nom en gros deux ans
groupe facebook mais y'a pas que
facebook est aussi instagram mais aussi
les autres filières de de facebook vous
venez du monde universitaire français du
cnrs je crois avant d'être recruté par
facebook qui vont vous dirigez la
recherche sur l'intelligence
artificielle et puis je signale au
passage que vous êtes aussi
l'heureux propriétaire d'une maison dans
les yvelines ce qui est nouveau ce qui
fait que vous de vous un very important
people des yvelines alors on va essayer
d'avancer pas à pas parce qu'on va
aborder deux domaines que tout le monde
ne possède pas évidemment d'abord un mot
sur l'intelligence artificielle
on a l'impression que c'est l'avenir
mais elle est déjà là l'intelligence
artificielle on s'en sert tous les jours
c'est à dire que l'artificier le futur
c'est c'est le présent quand on va sur
sur internet smartphone pour faire que
ce soit des chaussures facebook sur
instagram par exemple aussi sur toute
une quantité de l'ap il ya une annonce
officielle qui tourne derrière pour
permettre à ses services de fonctionner
alors si on veut pour définir un peu au
groupe à ce que ce qu'est l'intelligence
artificielle est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'il ya eu 2 deux périodes au fond une
première période où on mettait dans des
machines le savoir ddd des hommes afin
de savoir qu'on avait acquis c'est la
première période et puis la deuxième
période qui est celle de l'intelligence
artificielle ou c'est la machine qui
apprend par elle même voilà en fait il
ya vraiment une accélération
l'intelligence artificielle depuis
dirait 5 5 à 10 ans qui a été oublié
l'arrivée de ce qu'on appelle la machine
learning apprentissage machine qui après
7 61 ans diplômé ou apprentissage
profond en français et en fait le
changement qui a eu l'intelligence
officielle d'avant parce que
l'intelligence sociale senio on a des
années 50-60 une accélération des
dernières années c'est effectivement
talent et avec ce qu'on appelait des
systèmes experts ça veut dire qu'en fait
finalement l'intelligence de la machine
était très limité mais il ya beaucoup
d'intelligence humaine qui permettait à
la machine fonctionne et c'est avec les
humains donné beaucoup d'informations la
machine etc depuis les dix dernières
années on a changé et maintenant
effectivement les machines soca point va
prendre par elle-même à résoudre
certaines tâches en leur montrant des
exemples donc pour résumer au lieu de
leur dire qu'est ce qu'il faut faire on
leur montre ce que ce qu'on aimerait
qu'elle fasse d'accord donc un exemple
que j'ai que j'aime bien pour fixer les
idées c'est la reconnaissance de
caractères manuscrits qui sert tout le
temps par exemple quand on écrit sur une
tablette à la main et quand vous êtes
sarko n'est directement ce qu'on ait ça
transforme en mots et bien jusqu'à
l'arrivée de l'apprentissage profond on
avait des méthodes qui disait que par
exemple en 5 c'était s'était formée
d'une barre horizontale une barre
verticale et un demi cercle ok plein de
définition comme ça donc il y avait
évidemment il ya plein de cinq
différents donc y aurait beaucoup de ce
qu'on appelle ses règlements et depuis
10 15 ans nous fait plus ça remonte
énormément de l'image de 5 à leurs
machines écrit par différents noir et
ont dit non au tour à trouve comment on
les reconnaît en cinq mois ce que je
donne juste des exemples de 5 et bien ça
c'est un changement et sauf que ça
maintenant on fait pas juste pour
reconnaître les caractères on fait pour
d'innombrables d'âge oui voilà on
pourrait pendre des emails par exemple
regarder des animaux connaître un chien
par exemple ou un chat un mais alors est
ce que est ce que la machine c'est ce
que c'est un chien par elle comme pour
sa
part ans mais est ce que c'est que guéna
qui aboie l'autre qui miaule break
en fait on a machine mais être capable
de trouver des
des motifs et des
des informations des connexions non dans
ce qu'on les montre qu'en fait on va lui
montrer effectivement des vidéos par
exemple de chats et de chiens mais on va
pas dire ce qu'est un chat un chien les
concept n'existait pas dans la machine
en tout cas une façon pour les enfants
les voient mais elle va arriver à
reconnaître que cette forme à quatre
pattes effectivement c'est un animal qui
n'est pas le même que sept autres fort à
quatre pattes alors après tout une
question qui est actuellement dans
l'intelligence sociale c'est qu'on
rappelle l'interprète habilité c'est à
dire que ok l'arraché indique ça c'était
un animal et apprend l'unique ça c'est
animal rappelle chien elle dit que ça
c'est pas le même animal c'est un autre
animal cauhapé de chats et où elle peut
faire ça après ce qui va être
intéressant c'est le lien mais pourquoi
est-ce que ça c'est un chien est pas un
chat voilà et donc ça et que la machine
soit 40 de répondre et ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle la paix et à la stabilité
c'est-à-dire qu'on veut des machines qui
soit capable d'encore langage humain
c'est en leur parlant de nous dire
pourquoi ils ont pris cette décision
avec les autres par exemple pour tous
l'exemple pour votre exemple patrice
c'était à elle j'ai dit que c'était un
chat parce qu'on fait ça à quatre pattes
sans ressemblant le chat mais s'est mis
d'accord et il ya une question est
d'ailleurs critiquée que ça pousse vous
mêmes vous savez je pense à vous et je
crois fait des recherches vous même avez
fait départ dont des applications ou
pour pour des avec l'intelligence
artificielle pour
par exemple expliqué des thèses de thèse
universitaire assez complexe et la magie
ni arrive ça à faire des résumés par
exemple oui ça c'est quelque chose qui
est
bien et il ya ce qu'on appelle le régime
autocratique c'était effectivement de
donner un document ça c'est un peu le
rêve
d'avoir un document
tous ces exemples en tête le document de
30 40 60 70 pages est d'être capable
d'en faire une note de synthèse en une
page de page donc ça et encore une fois
la manière dont l'intelligence
intelligence fonctionne maintenant c'est
à dire qu'on va parler dire comment il
faut faire on va lui montrer des
exemples des documents et de résumer et
on va dire maintenant tu débrouille
qu'apprend a résumé et maintenant je
donnerai des nouveaux documents et tu
veux mais résumer pas ce qu'on a fait
aussi en partenariat avec une
association une api une association pour
les parents les amis d'enfants
handicapés
et et l'inria qui est le grand
établissement de recherche en
intelligence artificielle de public
c'est un projet qu'on appelle la
simplification de texte qui est quelque
chose d'assez intéressant aussi sont en
fait on va donner du du texte en
français et on va demandant la machine
le simplifier qu'il soit plus facile à
comprendre pour des personnes qui sont
en situation de handicap en particulier
les handicaps mental et la sq au volant
la machine de faire c'est faire des
phrases plus courtes à faire des phrases
à la forme active enlever le vocabulaire
compliqué etc etc et ça en fait c'est
intéressant c'est actuelle aussi on l'a
appliqué à l'est pour aller les
attestations aux déplacements pendant le
premier qu'on filme en fait il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup d et franchement elle
était extrêmement compliqué à comprendre
et bien en fait on a fait avec cet outil
une façon plus simple que même moi
j'utilise est
souvent en vain quand on veut pas d'eux
notamment et parce que ces machines sont
censés aussi prendre des décisions elles
mêmes il ya en effet il ya ya ya ceux
qu'on connaît il ya le savoir il ya les
probabilités il ya aussi la psychologie
et on se demande toujours voilà est-ce
que ces machines d'intelligence
artificielle sont capables de
psychologie est ce qu'ils aient une
dimension psychologique dans ces
machines là il ya à cette question
ouverte parce que
encore une fois les les machines sont
capables de faire je parle de magie qui
sont capables d'apprendre à partir
d'exemples mais elles vont être capables
d'apprendre à partir de ce qu'on leur
demande d'apprendre aussi c'est quand
même la machine dont je parlais à
l'instant qui est capable de faire de
simplification texte elle est capable de
faire que de la certification texte
qu'elle va pas se lever un matin et
d'airbags voilà maintenant je vais aller
à prendre a conduit une voiture aux
pratiques où je verrai apprendre à jouer
aux échecs elle sait faire que quelque
chose donc en fait là les questions de
conscience des machines psychologique
c'était à sa seconde pour des modèles et
des machines qui sont conçus pour ça et
en particulier on parle
jean conversationnel d'agents qui vont
être capables de discuter avec des
personnes on parle aussi de chat vote de
temps en temps et il ya des chercheurs
en psychologie qui conçoit des shadoks
l'intelligence artificielle pour des
études de psychologie mais c'est quand
même
spécialisée s'était faite on va pas
commencer à croire que parce que machine
est capable de faire du résumé elle a
aussi un focus écologique
je vous pose cette question parce qu'il
ya toujours des grands débats il ya on
voit si on regarde pour ou contre
l'intelligence artificielle comme si on
pouvait être pour ou contre ce qui on
s'en doute un peu un peu un peu idiot
mais il ya beaucoup de fantasmes et
parfois de peur comme si avec cette idée
que la machine pourrait devenir autonome
c'est ça qui crée un peu là parfois la
la crainte de l'intelligence
artificielle
des matches tout à fait légitime et de
toute façon
l'intelligence artificielle en fait moi
la manière je décris c'est que ça hein
griffi un ensemble d'outils qui sont
capables de faciliter et de rendre plus
rapide ou moins compliquées un honorable
ensemble de tâches on a parlé un petit
peu de traduction simplification voilà
énormément donc c'est des outils d'après
moi j'aimerais bien j'aime bien c'est
pareil les outils d usage le nom donc en
fait par exemple à la traduction
automatique
donc on en fait beaucoup ça peut servir
énormément de choses qui peuvent
permettre aux gens de communiquer aux
gens de d'avoir accès à de l'information
il ya des gens munis de ces énormément
de neige pour ce concert beaucoup de
contributions génétiques je pense que
personne dirait qu'il faut arrêter
l'instruction thématique parts mais
néanmoins on voit quand même des pirates
informatiques ont accordé les gens qui
font du du spam qui se servent
énormément la traduction automatique
parce que vous êtes au lieu de pouvoir
se permet simplement en anglais avait
entre autres en garde est-ce que donc ça
sert plus à risque évidemment
il
comprend dalle mais en fait ça veut pas
dire que parce qu'à cet usage tout le
genre de la traduction et auchan et
d'ajouter moka vraiment je pense les
enjeux son couteau ou est-ce que ça va
et comment est ce qu'on leur pique une
des grandes questions étaient posées par
l'intéressé difficiel c'est une
rencontre spéciale est très facile pour
une machine de faire une reconnaissance
faciale quand c'est beaucoup de
recherches là dedans c'est quelque chose
qu'on imagine à faire très bien et bien
ça veut pas dire que la machine peut le
faire ça veut pas dire qu'on va le faire
donc il ya vraiment deux ans et par
exemple a meta on a annoncé l'année
dernière pour arrêter tous dans le
combat sans spatiale de tous les temps
tous les services seront agraire avant
d'ivoire a appelé facebook il ya
quelques années on pouvait taguer les
gens parce qu'en fait c'était comme une
image vaut les étiqueter c'est plus
possible on a arrêté on peut le faire
techniquement c'est pousser aux arbres
on pense qu'éthiquement au pas le faire
donc on la rend donc à rien pour moi ya
vraiment un enjeu entre la 10 mai la
technologie peut faire et quels sont les
usages et en fait finalement sarah jour
beaucoup de débats sur la technologie
alors dans ces débats il ya 7 7
cette tribune dont on parle beaucoup qui
avait signé notamment stéphane hawkins
et elon musk c'était sur les robots
alors qu'ils disaient voilà il ya un
danger le jour où les robots vont
s'apercevoir que il ya juste les humains
qui peuvent les débrancher bac s qu'ils
ont faim ils vont se révolter contre les
humains c'était c'était c'était cette
première première critique il y en a une
autre à leur pic et d'un chercheur qui
s'appelle stuart russell qui dit lui
c'est l'accident il dit par exemple si
si on demande à l'intelligence
artificielle bah qu'est ce qui fait qu
est ce qui augmente par exemple la
température enfin le look du climat et
l'intelligence artificielle va dire ben
c'est l'activité des hommes donc pas le
plus simple c'est de supprimer les
hommes
parlent de l'accident en fin de de
l'intelligence artificielle
vous en pensez quoi tout ça est ce
qu'ils vont être aussi inquiet que ça ou
est-ce que c'est plutôt les bénéfices au
plus fort que les risques j'en pense aux
gens pensent deux choses 1 je pense que
c'est important que à des experts comme
si entre celles je tenais
personnellement par exemple et et
l'autre de poser des questions posées
des bons pour moi je pense que le danger
c'est plutôt que la technologie arrive
soit pris les gars quand même les gens
se lassent pas surpris et quand je dis
les gens et les utilisateurs c'est les
législateurs etc je pense qu'il faut
mettre les débats sont intenses et après
sur l'aspect la machine va dire décidé
que pour sauver le climat
sur le climat il faut supprimer humain
voilà oui c'est vraiment du financement
et la science fiction certes ça veut
dire quelqu'un qui l'aurait il aurait
attaché à un logiciel qui permettait de
supprimer donc ça ne veut pas on peut
faire des logiciels qui font des nachi
qui vont faire des raisonnements
abracadabrantesque c'est pas difficile
c'est la question c'est que vous faites
ces raisonnements la hesse conscience
etc donc voilà donc je pense qu'il faut
être un peu raison garder sur cette voie
un petit peu points il ya aussi une
métaphore sur les greens de trop bonne
que je peux vous dire si vous voulez oui
mais attention allez-y l'efficience et
de métaphores traumat c'est à dire que
si gênant conseil mais rechigne dont
l'objectif une antinomie ciel de
l'objectif et construit des trombones
d'accord et qu'on est là et qu'on la
fait pas de bonne façon et bien en fait
on peut la laisser tourner elle m'a
s'auto tournée elle va s'auto aussi et
on va retrouver avec la terre qui va
être couverte de troubles
moi c'est le voile à l'airial dire que
oui mais je vois c'est qu'on voit cette
ville espèce de penser pense pas qu'il
ya deux des fondements technologiques
non non mais c'est toujours un peu la
même la même question celle composée
avec l'arme atomique par exemple c'est à
dire que ce sont quand même des
constructions qui peuvent et qui risque
un moment d'échappée c'est un peu ça qui
fait nos craintes n'ont cessé au fossé
c'est le le problème qu'on a avec toutes
les toutes les constructions kiki et qui
sont tellement intelligente qu'elles
peuvent voilà qu'elles peuvent échapper
c'est la crainte que les gens c'est ça
tu te fais à nyon on en fait vraiment
risqué
actuellement c'est que c'est un effort
mais un complément globale sur la
planète déjà par rapport à l'ère
nucléaire qui était par certains pays
donc c'est global et c'est surtout
énormément porté par la communauté open
source la plupart de l'intelligence
sociale et d'un logiciel libre donc ça
veut dire quand tu y es tu vois ce que
j'aime beaucoup dans cette communauté
c'est que finalement c'est ça donne
beaucoup d'opportunités aux gens de se
lancer l'intelligence artificielle
puisqu'il peut avoir accès aux logiciels
libres pour commencer à construire est
aussi ça permet aussi aux gens de
regarder en fait les experts en
intelligence fonctionne aujourd'hui
doivent regarder dans le dans le code
civil regarder où est ce qu'on en dit
etc on n'est pas dans des choses en fait
il ya un programme secret pendant 30 ans
et en lorraine le temps de parler on est
vraiment dans l'extrême inverse où on en
parle beaucoup et comme ça au moins
c'est sur la place publique oui une
sorte de démocratie si on veut dire de
voilà deux de ces de ces intelligences
artificielles
on va peut-être passer si vous êtes
d'accord au deuxième thème alors que
pour des c c'est le métavers le 28
octobre dernier mark zuckerberg annoncé
la naissance de méthane on a dit vous
même en train de boire vous êtes le
responsable de la recherche il y a
semeta mais ta méthode si j'ai bien
compris ça regroupe les activités de
facebook d'instagram de wazza enfin de
ce qui appartient voilà en gros à deux
cas font des yeux car oui alain c'est
bien ça
une ambiguïté puisque en fait le groupe
s'appelait facebook il y avait aussi
mais facebook il y avait aussi
l'application facebook mais en voici
l'application instagram aura des arrêts
en fait quand on disait facebook à ce
qu'on parlait de l'entreprise l'entité
juridique ou de l'application bon bah là
au moins il n'y a plus d'ambiguïté et
une obligation s'appelle facebook
continue à fonctionner il y en a
d'autres et ya un manque qui s'occupe de
ces applications qui développe qui
s'appelle médaille alors mais tu as est
pas neutre 1 parce que ça ça renvoie à
ce nouvel univers qu'on appelle le le
métavers je crois d'ailleurs que les
investissements
de votre groupe sur le métavers des
synthèses et sont assez considérables je
crois que c'est dans les 10 milliards de
dollars
est ce que est ce que donc mais tu as ça
veut dire que au fond vous êtes en train
d'inventer de mettre sur pied ce nouveau
monde qu'on appelle le métavers
alors
c'est un salon m lemay moi ce que j'aime
beaucoup avec cette direction
on va en parler c'est déjà qu'en fait
on ne prend pas les gens par surprise
c'est la comète il ya un changement dans
l'entreprise il ya une direction
stratégique est annoncé on va aller vers
la création du metavers et on va aussi
parler de ce qu'est ce que ça veut dire
mais aussi ont fait avant de s'asseoir
construit et avant que ce soit
clairement défi de ce que ça va être
donc quand mathias est en jeu de dire
que nos pas surprendre les gens voilà
regardez maintenant entier de demain où
les langues et avery les faits comme ça
c'est vraiment un aspect de
reconstruction donc s'arrête pas à pas
ça va ça va arriver ça c'est quelque
chose que je trouve vraiment intéressant
et une des premières briques et où on
voit mark zuckerberg qui est qui emporte
ans et des objets là c'est les casques
de réalité virtuelle qui sont finalement
sur marché depuis quelques années déjà
et celui-là c'est le le quest 2 et 1 et
donc en fait il ya eu déjà des briques
et donc en fait effectivement là
maintenant il ya neuf ans une annonce
qui dit maintenant on a mis par enrique
on va y aller on va y aller aussi en
vous expliquant faire du roi donc ça
c'est le premier jeu très intéressant
donc la deuxième question c'est où va
les coups y aller mais on va où
est donc en fait là le point là c'est
que c'est pas trés qu'il ya quand même
certains éléments qui sont très très
importants 1 yara pas un mets ta mère
c'est d'ailleurs blue travers ces drames
des questions et vers des univers c1 ça
vient d'eux c'est la même racine il ya
univers
et metaverse et plusieurs verres ce
qu'ils sont plusieurs plusieurs
universités donc ça sera dans le futur
il y aura des milieux et donc virtuel
dans lequel on va aller je vais pas dire
au courage je pense qu'on va aller ap à
différents degrés et s'est élevé qu'à
vers ça sera l'union de tous ces lieux
vous pouvez voir ça comme étant
finalement un centre commercial ou
plutôt je pense que c'est lieu à une
foire un salon où il ya plusieurs stands
et en mettre les stands sera arrivé sont
amenés par plusieurs entreprises
différents par plusieurs entités
différentes mais on peut naviguer l'un à
l'autre puisque en face d'un stand à
l'autre ça s'est un peu l'enjeu pourquoi
est-ce que vous allez danser ce temps là
et qu'est-ce qui est ce qu'ils vont
faire et pourquoi metin s'intéresse à ça
on peut creuser mais le point le plus
important c'est que c'est devenu comme
le futur d'internet
depuis la création a toujours eu pour
mission de permettre aux gens de se
connecter ça commence avec les amis
après c'était les informations instagram
centre les crânes étaient dans les
utilisateurs watsa c'est la messagerie
on peut regarder toutes les applications
le point central c'est permettre aux
gens de se connecter et de faire des
groupes de communautés le métavers c'est
de rouvrir une version de ça sert qu'en
fait dans le futur et ça va être un
futur assez proche on va pouvoir se
rencontrer se retrouver se connecter en
famille au travail contre les marchands
et les acheteurs et c'est dans une
version internet qui sera on m'appelle
incarner cercle au lieu d'être un écran
plat comme ça en 2d comme je suis mon
urine et qu'on croit être en 3d dans un
environnement pour faire des choses
complications à palettes et du jour sont
pas encore faits reçoivent alors je
retiens une chose parce que ça c'était
un débat et c'est très important que
nous le disiez il y aura plusieurs
métavers parce que c'est avec easy aura
peut-être qu'un seul mort ce bond comme
il y a un univers y aurait 15 mai
taverne on vous dit il y aura plusieurs
dans lesquels on pourra aller les uns
les autres alors pendant exemple juste
pour illustrer sa
c'est une annonce très récente de
microsoft qui avait acheté à
activision-blizzard
de jeux vidéo qui a racheté pour je
crois à 65 milliards de dollars donc
c'est quand même très très chers c'est
parce que le sale l'enjeu c'est que
d'immenses ces deux pays division qui va
permettre de faire du divertissement
indentifié du jeu vidéo en métal heures
je prends ça comme illustration parce
que c'est finalement microsoft a pas
changé de nom mais cette acquisition de
l'investissement qu'ils font est aussi
de dire que microsoft va aller très très
fortement vers des enjeux mais ta mère a
eu avec l'un enquêterait jeux vidéo et
gaming alors que facebook l'a plutôt sur
la communication mais voyez
ça corroborent ce que vous disiez c'est
à dire que cet homme c'est pas c'est pas
c'est un monde vers lequel on va aller
de toute façon alors je reviens sur ce
que vous disiez vous disiez voilà bah ça
au lieu d'être en 2d comme ça va on va
être en 3d c'est comme si on était
ensemble mais c'est comme un monde
virtuel dans lequel si j'ai bien compris
on va passer par un avatar va créer un
avatar de soi même c'est pas tout à fait
soit qui va qui va dans ce monde c'est
son avatar
exactement donc il savait partie des
d'ailleurs c'est ce que vous avez juste
et à la route sur les écrans sur les
parties de des choses à définir et des
territoires aussi liberté que ses offres
erp qu'en fait quand on va se projeter
dans cet univers on va pouvoir avoir le
choix de la façon dont on veut se
projeter est ce que j'ai envie de me
projeter comme je suis lié aujourd'hui
bien sûr très réaliste raser ou est ce
que je fais me projeter rasé est ce que
je t'ai bronzé est ce que j'ai envie de
me projeter avec un costume qu'est ce
que j'aurais me projeter avec une autre
apparence voilà donc et les gens qui
réfléchissent beaucoup et cela ce disque
de toute façon il y aura plusieurs
avatars comme on a plusieurs amis
d'accord donc un avis bon week-end il ya
un avis canton au travail et un avis
quand on va peut-être en soirée que ses
claques
on aura plusieurs avatars aussi et il
est possible qu'un avatar du week-end
par exemple pour aller jouer avec les a
mis hors jeu maintenant que nous ferons
très différents l'avatar du lundi
après-midi on a une réunion dans le
métal heures avec son lac son équipe là
tout le monde aura d avatar peut-être
plus du classique donc il ya tout cet
enjeu d'un radar et la recherche seront
faits par exemple dans mon laboratoire
avec le laboratoire de réalité virtuelle
aussi elle qui ont pour elles c'est
comment créer ses avatars et en
particulier à quelque chose qui est
difficile mais intéressant
comment créer des avatars qui sont
extrêmement photo réaliste ça veut pas
dire que les gens voudront les utiliser
tout le temps qu'ils ont essayé des
choses qui sont très différents mais on
aimerait bien que parmi les options et
des avatars qui soit vraiment réaliste
avec des pigments labo la façon de
bouger et c'est comme ça vraiment on se
retrouve dans quelque chose qui est très
très réel en tout cas d'une apparence et
ça c'est effectivement extrêmement
difficile mais on revient en arrière
parce que là c'est grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle je suppose
qu'on va trés ses avatars
on voit c'est bien le dire les images
qu'on a autour d'où on est dans le jeu 1
et on voit assez bien les avatars dans
le jeu le 3d comme on commence un peu ma
chambre on joue au tennis on fait ce
qu'on veut enfin bon c'est facile mais
là on voit que ça prend une autre
dimension c'est à dire que ça prend une
dimension entrepreneuriale ça me prend
une dimension même de financière par
exemple il ya une chose sur laquelle qui
m'a interrogé c'est qu'on voit beaucoup
par exemple d'achat de terrains virtuels
sur le méthane est rasé là ça existe
déjà et à des prix
importants très important même et on se
dit mais à quoi ça sert d'acheter un
terrain virtuel terrain à comprendre
construire une maison inhabitée mais un
terrain virtuel
oui mais c'est c'est encore une fois
c'est la suite d'internet donc donc je
pense qu'il s'est vraiment la bonne
image à voir des gens surtout quand
internet a commencé les gens et les
marques en particulier ont acheté aussi
du terrain sur internet on se rappelle
pas mais c'est les fameuses bannières
publicitaires
c'est du terrain en 2d serre sur une
plage on achetait la colonne de droite
on a chez la colonne du vote et ont
affiché le cube d'accord la maintenant
dans le métavers et vrd ya le pari de
céleri danser les précurseurs ces gens
qui créent ces terrains et des gens qui
les achètent c'est de se dire que ces
terrains ils vont être lancées par des
gens et gens vont y passer soit pour
aller acheter des choses sur le terrain
parce qu'il ya aussi des magasins qui
vont se créer l'avoir acheté soit et
bien en fait je raté un qui est bien
placé des gens il ya du trafic dessus
donc je vais pour mettre des pubs dessus
exactement comme les bannières
exactement comme avant les panneaux sur
les routes pourquoi on est un peu sur la
même logique est-ce que la chose c'était
un c'est une bannière est aujourd'hui
c'est parce que je suis pas un expert en
marketing digital mais en tout cas c'est
cette logique là il ya quelque chose
donc à cet enjeu business on peut
marcher et commerces alors on pourra en
parler il ya aussi un autre aspect qui
rebondit encore plus près de nous c'est
l'aspect du travail et qui a été
accélérée énormément avec la province
voilà on fait cette interview en
visioconférence on n'a pas énormément
digue où on a tous énormément visé
confiance et bien le matin vers ça
permet de faire des réunions au lieu
d'être par écran interposé d'être assis
autour d'une table chacun avec son nez
chacun chez soi avec son casque et on
est autour d'une table avec des avatars
virtuels et ça c'est déjà chose que nous
ont fait leur en équipe comme les rayons
on est
réparti grave et on fait des réunions en
réalité les yeux d'ailleurs il ya dedans
ça va
meta et facebook c'est une entreprise
très innovante mais plus les entreprises
d'ailleurs sont innovantes je pense aux
startups et pluie ya des modes de
travail innovants comme celui-là qui
sont arrivés même avant que avant
l'apport débit qui a obligé beaucoup
d'entreprises ire coréen
il ya aussi beaucoup j'ai vu qu'ils
avaient beaucoup aussi de deux boîtes de
mode luxe de joaillerie et qui
s'intéresse aussi à ça là aussi c'est
encore une fois moi c'est vrai ma
conviction c'est par un futur possible
c'est un futur probable mais après ça
donc il va y avoir du marché qui va être
fait les prix de marché lors des achats
qui va être fait ce qu'on ne peut pas
vraiment quantifier et combien et moi il
ya quelque chose aussi qui exploit
important a dit stricker c'est que
remplace pas le monde réel des fois il
ya des gens qui a oui ou non en fait ça
remplace je pense mon présence online on
passe déjà beaucoup de temps sur les
écrans dans sur les téléphones sur des
ordinateurs je pense que c'était devant
la télé ou deux jours avant les jeux
vidéo ça c'est des usages actuels ou
presque de ce temps là il m'a rien à
voir qui va se déporter dans le métavers
sais pas combien etc mais là le fait
d'aller au restaurant physique de voir
ces gens très hauts placés voilà ça va
pas être au monde doit rester tout seul
chez soi sur son canapé avec son casque
tout l'avion décolle pour on pourra
sortir que ma maison c'est aussi partie
de la construction un peu global c'est
bien recruté on est déjà déjà des gens
lèvent la sonnette d'alarmé
pour lui le pur l'addiction pour les
allemandes on peut travailler déjà très
en amont sur ces questions là où le se
rend compte après 10 à 20 si j'avais su
d'ailleurs oui des créateurs de mode qui
disent voilà on pourra acheter une robe
sur le métavers la faire porter à son
avatar et puis peut-être après si ça
nous plaît peut-être la refaire venir
dans le monde réel un face c'est peu
s'il peut y avoir des des interactions
mais il faut il faut voir que quand on
passe je sais pas comment
twitter la bataille même si on y parle
de trois heures pour un jour
c'est quand même beaucoup de temps on va
être viré va forcément un moment où les
utilisateurs le voir des fonds obtenus c
est comme dans nombre réel il ya des
gens qui ont aucun intérêt pour leur
apparence enfin un peu ce qui passe
elles ont fait la bêta et il ya des gens
qui veulent
afficher qui sinon vents qui vient
l'affiché qui sont à la dernière mode
qui veulent afficher qu'ils ont des
biens qui est donc en fait il y aura des
options on pourra acheter des objets
rares et donc ça connu qu'avec un mot
est un mot qui est très important et que
il ya aussi connecté aux médias mardi
sur la tension qui sont énergiques les
défaire les noeuds
voilà les
caisses du club donc c'est informatique
qui décline aussi qu'ils sont uniques on
peut marquer comme un taux unique et
bien
effectivement c'est nst on va pouvoir
une robe par exemple élèves t c'est un
travail je l'achète à ymare par exemple
ou un créateur d'ailleurs qu'il n'est
pas une marque c'est ce signe évolution
ce avec des gens vous pour arriver à
faire les choses
l'élève tétravalent que les gens
voudront et peut-être qu'ils vont
changer un peu la balance entre les
marques classiques et les marques en
tout cas je pourrais acheter une robe en
externat matin en corse après je lai je
leur apporte peut-être pour aller au
travail
et après quand je vais faire un jeu avec
des amis je la porte aussi ai-je en
revenir à c'est quoi cette robe voilà je
les achetais machin un jeune ça
m'intéresse donc il peut y avoir ces
choses là donc évidemment c'est les
objets virtuels mais c'est c'est très
différent que d'acheter une paire de
chaussures réel pour mettre une fois tu
avais un événement à voilà qu'il ya
encore une fois ces solutions
on va voir ce que ça donne le ft c'est
au fond le marqueur qui fait que vous
êtes le seul propriétaire
de ses biens virtuels c'est ça ouais
ouais vous êtes donc donc ça fait la
rareté et ça fait l'unicité alors
effectivement dans le virtuel lui qu'on
peut copier les fichiers voit la base on
pourra y ait enquête si j'achète une
paire de chaussures ne s'est pas moins
500 euros mais en fait c'est un gars tu
es mais c'est un fichier ils commettent
qui on peut se renvoyer par mail et je
peux le reproduire en eau fini ya plus
de valeurs locales alors que là
effectivement pour la fft l'enjeu c'est
que ces pièces de vote qui n'est pas
modifiable et qui et
authentifie de ça et c'est autorisé
parce qu'on appelle un bloc 7 mai afin
d'en vau va pas pouvoir tout
il faut dit il faut dire simplement que
chez ft le métal heures en fait tous se
connecter et il faut ajouter que tous
marchais se fait évidemment aux cryptes
au modèle
le plus peur du temps il va y avoir des
vrais gones est aussi mais effectivement
les méta leur second venir avec leur
monnaie ce qui est déjà en a pas parlé
mais il ya déjà des metal heures qui
sont en activité on parle par exemple
eurobloc ce qui est très populaire chez
les jeunes adolescents pour adolescents
américains européens
entre 8 et 12 ans par exemple pour faire
des jeux c'est un environnement en 3d
les enfants ce point la bataille est
âpre et peuvent jouer ensemble de jeux
et leurs avatars madore jeunes ya une
monnaie dedans et on peut acheter les
objets emploi et qui ont peut être bien
ce matin et c'est un autre un autre je
le peux de type métal heures qui est qui
marchent aussi très très bien ses formes
nike
nike un jeu qui a énormément de succès
qui fait un revenu colossal la forte at
on peut avoir un avatar aussi mon équipe
non il peut aller d'un d'une partie à
l'autre on peut l'équiper il ya même des
communautés ou avec des gens se
retrouvent pour jouer mais pour discuter
aussi ils les concerts de personnes
vient de personnes réelles qui ont fait
un concert avec leur avatar dans vente
ait les gens insisté donc c'est ça c'est
bon vieux lycée pas un peut-être un
futur possible c'est déjà demain cette
future est quoi ca va etre est
d'ailleurs puisqu'on parlait des nfc le
monde de l'art est déjà très liée aux
élèves étaient d'ailleurs à base à
l'aller d'édition miami d'art basel a
consacré une de ces parties où edf type
ce qui est des oeuvres d'art qui sont
vendus jusqu'à 69 millions
en enfin en ft justement
pour conclure parce que finalement c'est
assez sensible c'est passionnant ce que
vous racontez ce que vous nous dites que
vous nous expliquer et et finalement
c'est c'est assez bien parce que ça ça
nous montre un modo faut c'est un monde
nouveau quand même
incontestablement même équipe alors il
ya plusieurs façons de voir mais la
façon dont vous le décrivez c'est plutôt
un mode plutôt excitant finalement non
moi je pense que oui je pense qu'il faut
le faire de façon responsable
et le faire de
démons principe je pense que celle-ci
attachés et chance le premier principe
qu'on la met en place c'est de le faire
de façon ouverte présent et on sait
qu'on va aller vers la est comme ça
beaucoup moins les questions arrivent
tout de suite chaque fois donc de le
faire a posteriori et bien voilà comme
on l'a fait
c'est trop tard c'est donc après c'est
hyper excitement je pense pourquoi un
retour plein d'enjeux je vous parle des
enjeux aussi de transport donc on gage
aux mamans n'y a pas si longtemps pour
qu'on pouvait traverser le monde pour
faire une réunion de trois heures
c'était ça arrivait encore beaucoup
maintenant on peut cuire en
visioconférence les gens veulent pas le
faire parce qu'on n'a pas l'interaction
pareil peut-être que dans deux ans ça
sera vraiment pour le moc agi parce que
mes au masque hop on se retrouve dans la
même salle on peut discuter rire etc et
voilà donc il ya des enjeux je pense de
connexion qui sont avant la vie assez
fort et des enjeux de création qui vont
être extrêmement novateur vous avez
mentionné les artistes dont tout un
nouveau monde de l'art qui va s'ouvrir
lnf des fonds qu en fait cet art peut
être rentable pour les artistes ça le
changement d'un complètement vous pouvez
faire des as d'art virtuelle vidéo et
c'est extrêmement créative mais est
difficile de les monnayer puisqu'en fait
elle peut être copiée à l'infini mais là
c'est plus le cas donc là les créateurs
je pense la mode les jeux vidéo il ya
énormément de création
donc donc voila et qui va être en lavis
superposés et ajouter à mon réel et on a
des entreprises françaises faut quand
même le dire parce que les américaines
mais dont le laboratoire est basée à
paris et on a aussi d'autres entreprises
françaises qui se positionne très bien
sur ce secret de moi aussi avec des
talents là les talents très très fort en
3d on a des talents très très fort wayne
jeux vidéo
ubisoft par exemple et on a aussi des
créateurs et des des entreprises qui
font la production de contenus de
divertissement des films des séries en
en 3d et en métal heures donc c'est
aussi quelque chose ne pas trop parler
mais les séries les films du futur ça
sera aussi des séries peut-être qu'ils
se déroulent et on est dans l'action et
en fait ça se déroule et on peut suivre
ses droits donc c'est une nouvelle façon
de voir le divertissement et on n'est
pas trop mal placé
c'est vrai qu'on est très bien placé et
coter autour de bordes merci infiniment
de cet éclairage passionnant merci
d'avoir accordé un peu de votre temps
jeu dont le sait qu'il est assez
précieux
est-ce qu'on travaille beaucoup quand
même dans les boîtes comme les vôtres
merci beaucoup aimé peut-être très vite
le voir là pour d'autres déclarent de
temps en temps ça serait bien qu'on
fasse cette phase la discussion
merci merci
[Musique]